las protestas de las que hablaban no han
sido las únicas reacciones y como lo
decíamos antes el jefe del cuerpo de la
guardia Revolucionaria islámica José
insanami sostuvo que los musulmanes se
vengaran tarde que temprano explícanos
por qué la reacción de Irán Y cómo
entender estas palabras
buenas tardes gracias por la invitación
tenemos que entender todo esto como una
típica propaganda del régimen iraní
cuando se ve acorralado y encuentra que
no tiene otra salida que por ejemplo
amenazar con a este periodo satírico
Como hizo en su momento contra salmany
por lo tanto nos tenemos que lo tenemos
que entender En clave de la gran
utilización de los medios de
comunicación del régimen para desviar un
poco también la atención porque siguen
reprimiendo la gente siguen presionando
las personas que protestan contra el
régimen porque en Irán hay toda una
maquinaria represora que está contra la
población que está pidiendo No ya
pequeños cambios en un cambio total de
régimen
y usted habla precisamente de las
manifestaciones que ha habido y los
cambios sin embargo el régimen ha
respondido condenando a la orca a cuatro
personas y también Busca la pena de
muerte para otras 26 esto puede suprimir
la que ha sido la peor agitación
política en los últimos años o por el
contrario la indignación puede promover
todavía más las manifestaciones
seguramente tenemos que evaluar la
represión que está haciendo el régimen
actualmente no está sacando toda su
maquinaria posible a la hora de reprimir
la población porque es una cuestión de
decisión política pero sí que es verdad
que todos los movimientos y las
manifestaciones que están saliendo hoy a
la calle tienen como respuesta la
represión
en la cárcel Las violaciones la tortura
y la pena de muerte porque al final La
amenaza de pena de muerte es un arma
política para tanto por un lado que las
personas que sigan saliendo a
manifestarse se sientan intimidadas como
para dar una respuesta a la comunidad
internacional
Por cierto que además de veinte mil
personas
en la cárcel sin garantías legales y de
ellas más de 100 están amenazadas por la
ejecución de forma inminente así que
tenemos que seguir siendo los iranes de
fuera los que estemos dando voz a la
lucha de las mujeres y los hombres
iraníes valientes que salen cada día a
pesar de las alabanzas del